Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler "faits divers".
Je vous rassure, rien de sordide,
3 arnaques.
Vous allez le voir, plus c'est gros,
plus ça passe.
Comment la Tour Eiffel a été vendue en pièces détachées ?
Comment des greffes d'organes,
d'un genre très spécial,
ont été promises à des patients
pour augmenter leur virilité ?
Enfin, comment une femme a réussi
à se faire passer pour Jeanne d'Arc ?
Pour cela, je suis accompagné par David Chemla
et ça, ce n'est pas une énigme,
vous l'avez déjà vu sur le compte TikTok Épicurieux.
On commence à Paris avec une affaire
qui s'est déroulée il y a un tout petit
peu moins d'un siècle.
Voici l'histoire de Victor Lustig, un arnaqueur de haut vol,
qui a réussi à vendre la Tour Eiffel
en pièces détachées.
Pas celle-ci, la vraie.
Nous sommes en 1925,
36 ans après son inauguration,
la Dame de fer n'a plus trop la cote.
Souvenez-vous qu'à l'origine,
il était même question de la démonter
juste après l'Exposition Universelle de 1889.
Eh bien, disons
qu'elle ne fait toujours pas l'unanimité.
Elle commence à rouiller
et son entretien coûte extrêmement cher
à la mairie de Paris,
qui en est devenue propriétaire.
Quant à Gustave Eiffel, son créateur,
il n'est plus là pour tenter
de la rendre indispensable
avec des expériences scientifiques
puisqu'il est mort.
Bref, on ne sait plus trop quoi en faire.
Mais Victor Lustig, lui, il a bien une idée.
Il est autrichien et c'est
un parfait escroc.
Il a été proxénète
avant de plumer de riches vieilles dames
sur les paquebots
lors des croisières transatlantiques
mais cette fois,
Lustig a mis la barre très haut.
Il veut vendre la Tour Eiffel en pièces détachées.
Aussi dingue que cela puisse nous paraître,
à l'époque, ça ne choque personne.
En effet, nous sommes au lendemain
de la Première Guerre Mondiale
et la France a besoin
d'acier pour se reconstruire.
Or, il se trouve que la Tour Eiffel
est construite en acier,
en fer "puddlé" précisément.
7300 tonnes
Si la Dame de fer ne sert plus à rien,
pourquoi ne pas aller
puiser dans cette manne ?
Il ne reste plus qu'à mettre
au point l'escroquerie
et autant dire
que Victor est sacrément gonflé.
Il se procure des faux papiers
et se fait passer
pour un haut fonctionnaire
mandaté par la ville de Paris.
Puis, il invite dans le prestigieux
hôtel de Crillon,
5 des plus grands ferrailleurs
de la capitale.
Parmi eux, Lustig a flairé un gros poisson
qui s'appelle justement André Poisson,
ça ne s'invente pas.
Après une visite privée en haut de la Tour Eiffel, ce pauvre poisson
mort à l'hameçon.
Lustig lui promet de lui
lâcher les 15 000 poutres
et les millions de pièces métalliques
de la tour
en échange d'un gros chèque et d'un joli
pot de vin.
Evidemment, quand la victime se rend
compte de l'arnaque,
il est déjà trop tard.
Le chèque a été encaissé
et Lustig est déjà loin.
A ce stade, évidemment,
on a tous envie de savoir
combien valait la Tour Eiffel en 1925.
Alors David, combien ?
Eh bien, on n'en sait rien,
car notre poisson pigeon
a eu tellement honte
qu'il n'a osé le dire à personne.
Victor Lustig a réussi
l'escroquerie parfaite.
Le problème c'est
qu'il est un peu trop gourmand.
Quelques années plus tard,
il retente le coup
mais cette fois, il se fait démasquer
et doit s'exiler aux Etats-Unis.
Là, il aurait pu se mettre au vert
et se faire oublier.
Mais non, il fait encore plus fort,
il décide d'escroquer la pègre.
Lustig s'attaque
au plus redoutable de tous,
Al Capone,
le parrain de la mafia de Chicago.
Il lui promet de doubler son capital
contre 50 000dollars.
Marché conclu.
Mais Capone se rend vite compte
qu'il a affaire à un escroc.
Toutefois, bluffé par son culot,
le mafieux ne lui en tient pas rigueur,
il lui aurait même pardonné
et aurait assuré sa protection en prison.
Car oui, notre célèbre escroc s'est
finalement
fait arrêter en 1935
pour une histoire de faux billets.
Il est alors condamné
à 15 ans de détention
dans la terrible prison d'Alcatraz.
L'histoire suivante
est complètement surréaliste,
les plus grands scénaristes
auraient eu du mal à l'inventer.
Au prétexte de booster la virilité de ses patients,
un pseudo chirurgien américain réussit
à les convaincre de se faire greffer des testicules de bouc.
Non, vous ne rêvez pas.
John Romulus Brinkley.
John Romulus Brinkley n'est pas médecin
mais il a toujours voulu le devenir.
Sauf qu'il n'a ni les compétences ni l'argent nécessaire
pour suivre de grandes études.
Qu'à cela ne tienne,
emporté par sa passion,
il achète dans les années 1910
de faux permis d'exercer la médecine.
C'est ainsi qu'il ouvre une pharmacie
et se constitue une fidèle clientèle.
Quelques années plus tard,
lorsqu'un fermier du Kansas
se plaint d'impuissance sexuel,
il se rend tout naturellement chez lui.
Brinkley lui fait
alors une drôle de proposition,
il suggère de lui transplanter
des testicules de bouc.
L'animal est connu pour être un symbole de virilité
en raison de son fort
taux de testostérone.
Le patient accepte et
au bout de quelques semaines,
son épouse annonce être enceinte.
Bon, elle l'était évidemment auparavant
ou bien le père n'est pas celui qu'on pense.
Toujours est-il qu'aussitôt
le succès est attribué
à l'intervention chirurgicale du médecin.
Dès lors,
il acquiert une solide réputation
et multiplie
les interventions du même type ;
il ouvre même une clinique.
L'intervention est facturée entre 750 et 1 500dollars
suivant la qualité du greffon.
Mais rien en revanche,
aucun commentaire sur les graves
complications
et les décès post-opératoires.
Pourquoi ce silence ?
Pourquoi le faux médecin n'est-il pas inquiété ?
En fait, il faut se remettre
dans le contexte de l'époque.
En 1918, la médecine ignore tout des mécanismes de rejet
qui se produisent
en cas de transplantation d'organes.
Mais bon,
on aurait quand même pu s'inquiéter
sauf qu'au même moment,
d'autres pathologies font des ravages aux Etats-Unis.
C'est le cas de la "grippe espagnole".
Beaucoup de médecins refusent
d'ausculter les patients victimes
d'infection, de crainte d'être eux-mêmes contaminés.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas de Brinkley
qui, lui, accepte de les recevoir.
Grâce à ces greffes, Romulus Brinkley gagne jusqu'à 15 000dollars par semaine.
Pardonnez moi l'expression,
mais là, on peut dire
qu'il se fait de véritable couilles en or.
On vante même ses exploits
jusqu'à Hollywood où il est invité
en grande pompe par le très puissant
patron du "Los Angeles Times".
Ce dernier consacre de nombreux articles à la success story
du magicien qui guérit les pannes sexuelles.
Romulus Brinkley
devient une véritable star.
Pour attirer toujours plus de patients,
il lance en 1923
sa propre station de radio.
Tous les soirs,
entre 2 morceaux de jazz,
le faux médecin répond aux auditeurs
et fait la promotion de ses miraculeuses
transplantations.
Sauf qu'à force de se mettre en avant,
Romulus attire de plus en plus les soupçons.
En 1930, le vent tourne,
on l'accuse de fraude et de charlatanisme.
Ses faux diplômes
sont publiés dans la presse
et l'ordre des médecins du Kansas
lui retire sa licence.
Qu'importe,
Brinkley contourne l'interdiction
en embauchant de vrais chirurgiens
qui poursuivent les opérations.
Et comme il n'a peur de rien,
il se présente comme candidat
au poste de gouverneur du Kansas.
Il perd, mais recueille tout de même 30% des voix.
En 1932, il s'installe au Texas où il ouvre un nouvel hôpital.
L'histoire se répète
et personne ne semble pouvoir l'arrêter.
Ce n'est que des années plus tard
qu'il est finalement poursuivi
par le gouvernement fédéral américain
pour faute professionnelle.
Des centaines de victimes portent plainte
et lui réclament d'énormes dédommagements.
Brinkley échappe à la prison
mais se retrouve complètement ruiné.
Il meurt en 1942 d'une crise cardiaque.
En 16 ans, on estime à 5000, le nombre de victimes
de ce qui est considérée aujourd'hui
comme la plus grande escroquerie médicale du XXᵉ siècle.
Nous allons maintenant
faire un énorme bond dans le temps.
L'histoire suivante débute en 1436.
Voilà 5 ans que Jeanne d'Arc
est passée de vie à trépas sur le bûcher,
quand une rumeur complètement folle
se répand dans le royaume.
La Pucelle d'Orléans
serait toujours en vie.
Mais comment est-ce possible ?
Le 30 mai 1431, à Rouen,
ils étaient des centaines à assister
à son supplice dans les flammes,
sous le regard des Anglais
qui ont ensuite jeté ses cendres
dans la Seine.
Pourtant, 5 ans plus tard,
dans un petit village près de Metz,
une jeune femme l'affirme haut et fort
"Jeanne d'Arc est en vie".
Et pour cause et elle le jure,
Jeanne d'Arc, c'est elle.
Il faut le reconnaître,
elle ressemble beaucoup à la Pucelle,
elle a la vingtaine,
une petite taille et une coupe au bol.
Pour certains nostalgiques de Jeanne
d'Arc,
c'est suffisant pour y croire mais
cela ne résout pas un problème majeur :
si cette fille est bien Jeanne d'Arc,
qui était celle qui a brûlé sur le bûcher ?
Une usurpatrice ou bien la vraie
qui a finalement ressuscité ?
Face à toutes ces questions,
la nouvelle Jeanne reste un peu évasive.
Elle n'est pas la première
à se faire passer pour Jeanne d'Arc.
À l'époque, d'autres femmes
affirment être la Pucelle
mais cette fois c'est un peu différent.
Plusieurs personnes
la reconnaissent et pas des moindres.
Il y a parmi elles, d'anciens
compagnons d'armes
ainsi que 2 de ses frères.
Alors, comment douter ?
L'histoire semble si vraie qu'en 1439,
la jeune femme est accueillie en grande pompe à Orléans,
le fief de la vraie Jeanne d'Arc.
Elle y rencontre le roi de France
Charles VII en personne.
En théorie, il devrait bien se connaître mais là, coup de théâtre.
Sans doute convaincue
que le roi ne sera pas dupe,
la jeune femme se jette
aux pieds du souverain et avoue tout.
Elle n'est pas Jeanne d'Arc,
elle se prénomme Claude des Armoises
et demande grâce.
Faute avouée à moitié pardonnée.
Mouais, pas cette fois,
car en septembre 1440
la fausse Jeanne d'Arc est condamnée
à Paris pour usurpation d'identité.
Elle est même suspectée d'hérésie.
Elle sera humiliée publiquement au pilori
mais s'en sortira mieux que la vraie Jeanne d'Arc
puisqu'elle échappe au châtiment suprême.
Je vous avais dit
que ces histoires étaient hallucinantes.
Je ne vous ai pas arnaqué.
Et avec David
on en a beaucoup d'autres sous le coude.
Alors, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à liker, à laisser des commentaires
et, bien sûr, à vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Allez à très bientôt,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.